- Follow your own Goddamn dreams.
Not what your mom wants you to do.
Not what your dad wants you to do.
I didn't enjoy what I was doing
and it felt like it didn't have a purpose
of me doing it.
The future for me, was
something like, ahhh.
I didn't even want to think about it.
How bad of a situation you're in.
Or how much the world
seems to be against you,
you're not going to be like that forever.
- He's a Swedish based comedian
and video producer, best known
for his video series on YouTube.
He dropped out of University, to focus
on his YouTube channel, much
to the dismay of his parents.
It worked out, though, and since 2013
he has become the number one,
most subscribed to
YouTuber on the platform.
He's PewDiePie, and here's my take
on his top 10 rules to success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite.
And I'm super curious to find out which
one you guys like the best.
Also, as you're watching the clips,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you.
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
And put quotes around it, so other people
can be inspired as well.
When you write something down,
it's much more likely to
stick with you too, enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- Even if I wasn't making videos now,
I've learned that you should really
follow your heart and you should do
what you want to do.
And what you are passionate about.
(laughs)
It's hard for me to talk about this,
but I really wasn't happy before
because it felt like, I didn't enjoy
what I was doing.
And it felt like it didn't have a purpose
of me doing it.
So, the future, for me, was
something really, like, ahhhhh.
I didn't even want to think about it.
And I learned a lot from this
YouTube, even about myself.
But no matter what, I want
to do what I love to do
and what I'm passionate about.
And I hope I can carry that
message onto you, bros.
I'm not saying (bleep)
school, or anything like that,
but you should definitely
follow what you want to do.
Absolutely.
Life is too short for doing
things you don't like.
Money is a topic that I
purposely try to avoid,
for the five years that
I've been making videos,
because I just feel like it's
not important, to anyone.
I just want to make entertaining videos.
Don't get me wrong, though.
I don't hate money.
(laughs)
I'm not going to pretend
like it doesn't matter to me,
because it matters to everyone.
But when I started doing YouTube,
I was in college.
I was on a student loan.
I couldn't even afford a proper computer
that I could record gameplay on.
So I was lucky, I managed
to sell some artwork
that I made, online.
And that's how I was able to get started.
Some of you know this story,
but shortly after, I quit college
and so I had to get a job.
And I took whatever job I could get,
which was to work in a hot dog stand.
And a lot of people
like to take this story
as something negative.
They're like, "Oh, he did that?"
Or, "I can't believe he
used to sell hot dogs.
"Now look at him, making big bucks."
It wasn't like that, at all, for me.
I was the happiest I was, at that time,
because I was finally, for the first time
in many, many years
doing what I wanted to do
and the fact that I could
make videos was so much more
important to me that I had
to spend a few hours a day
doing a job that wasn't that prestigious.
I didn't know, you could be
big at, well I know people
who were big at other types of videos,
but there was no one big at gaming.
And I didn't know you
could make money out of it.
So it was never like a career
that I just quit college
to pursue, it's just something
that I just love to do
and here we are five years later and it's,
it's exploded.
And what people, I guess,
don't really think about
until it's in their face is
that I have nine billion views
and that translates to something.
There's ads on my videos,
I make money out of those.
So whenever it comes out how
much I made a certain year,
people just get so shocked
and a lot of people also,
which I saw, were very, very angry.
They thought it was unfair.
They thought I just sit on my ass all day
and that I just yell at
the screen over here.
Which is true.
(laughs)
But there's so much more to it than that.
And I understand that people just,
haters are going to hate, right?
But I don't know, I
really think that money
doesn't make you happy.
I'm just as happy now
as I was five years ago.
I'm very happy that I don't
have to worry about paying rent
because that was a huge
issue when Marzia came over
to Sweden, we could barely afford it.
So, I'm happy about that,
but other than that,
it doesn't change much.
Everything happens for a reason.
I don't believe that and
that would be stupid,
but it's a really great
way to look at things
and it helps to keep a positive attitude
when you're in a bad situation.
Which is really hard.
And I know a lot of people
seem to think of problems
as this, just horrible thing
that should never happen
and if anything bad
happens, your life is over.
But really, think of how
boring anyone would be
if they never had to deal
with any kind of problem.
Like what kind of boring
person would that make you?
Problems help us grow.
It helps us become better
people because we learn
from them, just like mistakes.
But I also want to remind you that,
it's totally okay to be sad sometimes.
It's totally okay to
break apart a little bit.
Being happy all the time
is just not realistic.
And it's, it might
actually be a good thing.
Just remind you, things
will always get better.
Everything is going to be fine.
I don't care how bad of
a situation you're in
or how much the world
seems to be against you,
you're not going to be like that forever.
And if you fight through
it, which I know you can,
it will be worth it.
You just need time.
Everything's going to be all right.
Treat otters, treat otters?
(laughs)
Treat others like you want
to be treated yourself.
It might seem weird how helping
others will make yourself
feel better, but it's
been scientifically proven
that it does.
And keeping a positive energy or thought
around others, will keep out
your own negative thoughts.
I have gotten more out of
YouTube than I ever could have
possibly even dreamed about.
I would say try out different things.
That's how I started off.
Cause I started off
doing Call of Duty stuff.
Not a lot of people know that.
It's a fun game.
But I, all of a sudden I
wanted to try something else,
so I tried playing this
horror game and that's where,
I think, that my initial boom started,
from trying something else.
See how many spoons you
can balance on your face.
What's the point of this?
My job is so easy, I can
literally do what I feel like
and it's kind of amazing,
just the fact that I can
play video games for a living.
When I realized that for the first time,
like I was almost getting teary-eyed,
like, it was, my dream was come true.
♫ All this time I've been finding myself
♫ And I didn't know I was lost
I would be happy not to be number one.
(laughs)
I'm just a nerd who plays video games.
I don't, I didn't seek the spotlight.
How you look at yourself.
I get a lot of messages from you bros
saying you're not happy with who you are,
how you look like, if you're
overweight, I don't know,
and to be honest, it's not
something I know how to help
with because I don't
really struggle with it.
I feel content with who I
am and I want you to feel
the same way.
By any means, I'm not flawless,
so it's not about that.
It's just about being
happy with who you are.
People point out my flaws all the time,
especially since I'm on the internet.
Things that I didn't
even know was a problem
until people told me.
Like my forehead is too big.
I have a giant mole here which you might
not be able to see.
My nose is too wide.
(belches)
My chin is too wide, like long.
I have a Leno chin.
Not muscular enough.
All these things people tell me
and it maybe doesn't make me happier,
but the thing is (bleep)
what anyone has to say
about you and how you look.
No one has a goddamn right to point out
anything about your appearance.
Which gives you every single
right not to give a (bleep)
what anyone else has to say about it.
Your parents will tell you you can be
whatever you want to be
in life, which is true.
But what a lot of times
they don't tell you is that
you have to work really hard to get there.
And another thing maybe more importantly
is that you have to take risks.
You have to adventure into the unknown
and you might not know
what's going to happen
and that's scary but I think
it's always better to try
than not trying, no matter what.
Except meth, not even once.
I'm going, I could get an
editor and I could get help
with production and stuff like that
but I'm still the one
doing everything by myself
and I want to keep it that
way and I want that to be
kind of like an inspiration
for you bros, maybe.
I wanted you bros to feel
like, hey if Pewds can do it,
I can do it.
(laughs)
So if you have a dream or hopes out there,
you can just be like,
well if Pewds can do it,
I can do it.
Because, I don't know.
I like to be more proud of myself
than being proud of what
I got help doing, I guess.
I don't know.
Follow your own god damn dreams.
Not what your mom wants you to do.
Not what your dad wants you to do.
Not what you think you should be doing.
But, doing what you want to do
more than anything.
It's been said so many times before,
but really, if you don't
make your own decisions
in life, someone else is
going to make them for you,
and by the end of it, you won't be happy.
So, you might as well do
what it is you want to do.
I think, in general,
people probably see YouTube
as, it's very simple, anyone can do it.
And I think that's really cool,
but it is a lot of work for it.
I work a lot to get to where I am,
so I don't want people to go into it
and just think they can do it right away.
You can do anything you
want if you work hard,
and you got to be a little lucky too.
And I think I've been as well.
Look at that bridge, it fell.
Maybe you want to quit when things fail,
but you can't just fail when things quit.
("What a Feeling" by Irene Cara)
♫ First I was nothing
♫ But a slow glowing dream
♫ In the world
What the fuck am I doing?
♫ Light deep inside
Oh, sorry.
♫ And this little dream ah
What the fuck.
Oh god.
This is, no.
I didn't know it was this.
How am I supposed to?
Oh god.
No, no, no.
Don't look at me!
You like it.
You like this shit, don't you.
Oh, Edgar.
(grunts)
♫ Please believe it
♫ I can't
Oh my god.
I can, fuck, I don't know the, fuck.
♫ Passion
♫ And make it happen
♫ I can't hide
(mumbles)
Holy shit, I'm nailing it.
Yeah, that's right.
Witness dancing history
in front of you, bros.
Why does she keep touching
her body like that?
God damn sluts in the 90's, man.
If I get a heart attack,
write on my gravestone
that I danced fabulously.
Oh god, what is that?
I feel awkward enough.
Power mode, power mode.
Release.
Release the kraken.
Woo hoo hoo.
(screaming)
(laughing)
Yes.
Nailed it.
I hope you (bleep) enjoyed.
I'm going to go lie down for a little bit.
It was a good time.
(mumbles)
Love you, bye.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Christian Vargas asked me to.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I would also love to
know, what did you learn
from Pewdiepie today that's
going to have the biggest
impact on your life, on your business,
that you're going to immediately apply?
I'd love to hear from you.
Please leave it down in
the comments down below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout out
to Deej Martinez.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
It really, really,
really, means a lot to me.
And that picture you took with
the mirror is awesome, man.
I love it.
So, thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.